for the Cleveland Browns getting Odell
Beckham jr. at five years 77 million
dollars is a steal in comparison to what
other receivers are making now there's
no guarantee that Odell Beckham jr.
won't want a new contract now or in the
not-too-distant future but to get him
done to get him signed sealed and
delivered for the next five seasons in
exchange for a first-round pick a
third-round pick and safety Jabril
Peppers that just gives the Browns
something special that they can continue
to build around offensively from Baker
Mayfield to Jarvis Landry to Kareem hunt
if and when he's cleared to play and if
they don't have Kareem hunt they have
Nick Chubb they have David and Joe ku a
tight end it just feels like the Browns
were ready to become a special team and
that pressure is something that could
derail the Cleveland Browns they haven't
had the burden of expectation in decades
in Cleveland but with a guy like Baker
Mayfield at the center of this offense
at the center of this franchise have a
feeling they'll be able to handle it I
have a feeling they'll be able to get it
done and I have a feeling we're gonna be
talking a lot about the Cleveland Browns
and seeing a lot of Browns games on
Sunday Night Football and elsewhere in
primetime in the coming years
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports